Any more pages and stuff coming up.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
of course.
Think with psm.
I mean,
I was saying this to him,
to his wife.
It's like when you're making music and
writing and stuff,
oftentimes you quote the greats and you
know,
you quote a hunter s Thompson or you're
a young or whatever,
but they're all dead,
you know,
and they didn't.
They were already.
Or if there are audio recordings of
them,
they're not very good and there aren't
that many of them.
And here we have peterson like spitting
fucking napalm on a daily basis,
like dropping,
laying in hours of audio everyday.
It's all fucking brilliant.
It's all incredibly valuable.
And it's also incredibly sonorous
musical and beautiful and important and
necessary right now.
If I did nothing else in my life,
even if I didn't even eat,
I could just sit there making peterson
music forever because there's so much
material.
So,
um,
I will continue to make Peterson stuff
and it will continue to be useful when
there's also many,
many other things to draw into music and
make useful in that fashion.
It's basically,
it appears to be a new genre or at least
a new way of sort of communicating ideas
and stuff and I've always done it.
I've always made mixed tapes that bought
in people talking and bringing in ideas
and meeting musical.
Just like now there's a real big
appetite for it and thanks to those
lovely robots over at Youtube.
It's just an expanding universe of,
of a potential for people actually
wanting to listen to it and being able
to do it.
Isn't there will be a jd and low fi
genre?
Well,
there is no other people are doing it
now.
If you go,
if you go look it up,
there's actually loads of people doing
it now to like varying degrees of
success.
But lots of people are doing it and I've
been doing it with other things and
it's,
it's called meaning wave now.
Um,
someone called it that in a car.
There was a genre.
It's now,
yeah,
it's a thing.
It's called meeting wave.
Uh,
it combines music,
aesthetics of low fire and vapor wave
and vapor trap and,
and cloud rap and with meaningful spoken
stuff.
So it's not just peterson?
No,
it's now just,
it's Kinda like the intellectual dark
web thing I guess.
But with music,
yeah,
struggle for power size each other up
and elect the competent and they do that
at every level of society.
Side rail crew in southern Saskatchewan.
Rough guys,
like a lot of them have been in prison.
You know when you first came onto the
rail crew,
you got a stupid nickname and people
tease,
and I remember this one kid called
lunchbox because he came to the rail
crew with a lunch bucket that looked
like his moment packed in.
That was a bad idea.
So they him lunch buckets,
but she wasn't very happy about.
That was a mistake.
He should have taken it with a smile and
then he was always to bowman if you
asked him to do something even wide,
why
it's about 60 men on this stretched on
the trucks.
Soon.
Anonymous philosophers were throwing
pebbles out during her.
So on and so the gateway,
let's see if we can get that lunch
bucket.
And that was purposeful because he
didn't,
he couldn't take a job.
It's like,
well,
let's see if he could take this job,
and then it just got more and more
peevish and the pebbles got bigger and
bigger.
Learned anything from experience,
but you come.
It's like you take a job,
can you be useful?
Can you at least be amusing?
Is there something worthwhile?
No.
It's like,
okay,
well then you're rounding because you
never know when we actually might need
to depend on you.